today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
welcome to the show donald trump and joe
biden
had their first debate last night and
there was great interest in it we had 64
000 people watch live with me on our
streams and i want to go through what
happened
and i have really been struggling with
how to summarize
such an insane event and this analogy
came up the last time i was on with
joe rogan in general about the trump
presidency and
sometimes you know our instinct is to
analyze
things with the frameworks we're
accustomed to and
i can't really analyze yesterday's
debate with the frameworks we're
accustomed to because it was completely
insane it was the analogy i made to joe
rogan
if he's doing ufc commentary and one of
the fighters
sets the other fighter on fire and you
say that's an aggressive tactic it's
like no that doesn't even come close to
encompassing the absurdity
of what we're dealing with and i even
woke up briefly in the middle of the
night to have a sip of water
and i thought how do i explain what
happened last night so
i'm going to try we'll do it in pieces
and hopefully by the end we'll have
sort of an understanding of what the
hell went on last night and and maybe
more importantly its broader meaning in
the election and in the united states
now the top line
is i've never seen a debate this bad
that can mean a lot of different things
so i'll clarify but i've been watching
presidential debates since 1996
when i was a mere lad of 12. i've never
seen a debate devolve
into being so worthless as what donald
trump was able to turn last night
last night's debate into i asked some
people who are older
and have been watching debates longer
they don't remember any debate turning
into as much of a circus as what we saw
last night
so i think we can say with with
certainty that last night was the worst
debate in the history of presidential
debates
since they've been recorded and
broadcast either via audio or video
and my guess is given what we know about
prior debates earlier in american
history
that last night was the worst debate of
any debate we've seen in presidential
campaigns
now to get us into the conversation
let's discuss it
in terms of biden trump and the
moderator chris wallace
joe biden did okay now i'm not going to
lie to you and say biden just did great
and he was
dynamic and energetic and all of this
stuff there's no question that joe biden
was stumbling quite a bit it was not his
stutter that was the problem it was that
he seemed to struggle
sort of sequentially laying out his
views on some issues but he did okay
he didn't collapse as many trumpets were
hoping biden had four or five
good answers his closing was arguably
his best moment about voting which we
will get to
he had two or three zingers which i mean
it sucks that
that's even something that we look at
but if you were hoping for some zingers
he had a few donald trump made the
debate impossible
so donald we could argue like if you use
a chess analogy
joe biden had some good moves and he had
some inaccuracies
no blunders donald trump flipped the
board over
and threw the pieces into the trash and
he would not shut up he interrupted what
must have been 50 times
during joe biden's time to speak trump
would just
talk over him and insult him trump went
after joe biden's son for having a drug
problem trump said joe biden wasn't
smart
he made fun of him for the college that
he went to
trump did not substantively discuss a
single issue
and then there was the moderator chris
wallace now there are people saying
chris wallace did well given the
circumstances
there are others saying chris wallace
did poorly what we can't deny
is that chris wallace did not have
control over the debate chris wallace
was begging and pleading with donald
trump to stop interrupting joe biden
trump wouldn't listen chris wallace had
no ability to cut the mic of the
candidates
in order for him to have that both
candidates would have to agree to it i
can't imagine trump
would ever agree to that so chris
wallace as well intentioned as he might
have been was helpless to stop donald
trump
so what i can say is that wallace wasn't
equipped to take control of the debate
you can say well he wasn't given the
equipment
because the candidates decided there was
no mute button that wallace would have
access to
whatever he did as well as he could you
can say but he didn't take control of it
trump controlled it
now in terms of the level of discourse
that trump
forced upon us it couldn't have been
lower or more base or more embarrassing
complete inability to discuss any policy
in detail
facts and dignity did not matter trump
refused to condemn white supremacists
than militia groups and actually
this is the first clip we'll look at
trump activated
the militia groups by very coyly saying
they should stand by stand
by take a look at this clip but are you
willing tonight
to condemn white supremacists and
militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared let's do it
i would say almost everything i see is
from the left wing
not from the right what are you what are
you doing what are you saying i'm
willing to do anything i want to see
peace
sir say it do it say it do you want to
call him
what do you want to call him give me a
name give me a white surprise
stand back and stand by but i'll tell
you what
i'll tell you what now this of course
stand
by is something very very different than
stand down
and all sorts of white nationalists and
militia types
immediately tweeting that that was a
call from trump for them to be ready to
stand
by for the post-election period a
completely
ruinous moment for the discourse and for
the status
of the united states of america from the
debate so
now trump this is just one of a dozen
examples two dozen examples
trump just talking over biden not
allowing biden his time
like a petulant child be in that option
number one so you agree with bernie
sanders far left
on the manifesto we call it man that's
because you socialize medicine
look hey are you still not gonna listen
to him the fact of the matter is
i beat bernie sanders not pretty much
i've beat him a whole hell of a lot i'm
here
i'm here standing facing you would have
left two days
earlier you would have lost every price
oh he knows how to unsupervised tuesday
you got to look very lucky
now you might think david that sounded
like two clips that sounded like a clip
of joe biden talking
and a clip of donald trump talk talking
superimposed
no no that's how the debate went
throughout donald trump
i could play 12 clips like that for you
i could play 24 clips like that for you
i won't do it
maybe the lowest moment of the debate
was uh donald trump going after joe
biden's son
for having a drug problem i'm talking
about my son beau biden you're talking i
don't know
i don't know beau i know hunter hunter
got thrown hunter got thrown out of the
military
he was thrown out dishonorably
discharged that's not true he wasn't
cocaine use and he didn't have a job
until you became vice president what do
you mean
he made a fortune in ukraine in china in
moscow that is simply various
other places can you imagine going after
it's not even biden but going after
biden
because biden's son had a drug
problem this is a health issue when
trump
brings up joe biden's son's drug problem
it's like making fun of someone because
your kid has diabetes
it's like ridiculing someone because
your kid has
cancer that's what we're talking about
here
uh disgusting i mean just a complete
debasement of what at some point in
american history were substantive policy
discussions
some good biden moments here while trump
is repeating this idea
that biden will end the suburbs this
ridiculous idea
biden says trump wouldn't know a suburb
unless he took a wrong turn
into one michael left supporters and
once he does that it's over with but
if he ever got to run this country and
they ran it the way he would want to run
it we would have
our suburbs would be gone by the way our
suburbs would be gone
and you would see problems like he know
it was a suburb unless you took a wrong
turn
oh i know celebrities when biden
did land zingers trump really wasn't
able to reply which was interesting
often
uh biden would just say no you no you
i'm sorry
trump would say no you know you and and
did not
the the point is when biden was able to
put together
a quick retort trump actually didn't do
so well biden at one point calling trump
a clown
they've you've already fired most of
them because they did a good job
some people don't know but here's it
with you guys
wait a minute you get the final word
well it's hard to get any word in with
this clown excuse me this
hey let me just tell you no no so as you
can see it's a very low level of
conversation there
hilariously there were some trumpists
who focused on that moment to claim that
it was biden who was being indecorous
during the debate because he used the
word clown about donald trump
you're sort of missing the forest for
the trees if that's your takeaway and
then one more moment
joe biden saying that donald trump is
the worst president
that the country has ever had when
donald trump tried to interrupt joe
biden
tax code that made him
put him in a position that he pays less
tax than a school teacher
makes on the money a school teacher
makes is because
of him take he says he's smart because
he can take advantage of the tax
code and he does take advantage of the
tax code that's why
i'm going to eliminate the trump tax
cuts and we're going to we're going to
eliminate those taxes
and make sure that we invest in the
people who in fact
need the help people out there need help
but why didn't you do it over
the last 25 years
in 47 months i've done more than you've
done in 47 years
joe now one of the things biden did do
well
and i thought that this was a good
approach and biden actually did this
really well if you go back and watch the
2012 debate biden did with paul ryan
um something joe biden did really well
was to laugh
off some of the dumb things that trump
said authoritarians like trump
narcissists like trump they want people
to be mad
people like trump want to cause anger
because it's beneficial to them and they
think they can take advantage of it and
when biden would just laugh
trump didn't like it take a look at one
example people want their schools open
they don't want to be shut down they
don't want their estate shut down they
want their restaurants i look at new
york it's so sad what's happening in new
york it's almost like
a ghost town and i'm not sure it can
ever recover what they've done in new
york
people want their places open they want
to get back to their lives people
they'll be careful but they want their
schools
i'm the one that brought back football
by the way i brought back big 10
football
it was me and i'm very happy to do it
trump never once reacted well
when joe biden laughed and that to the
extent that it was a strategy i think
it's just biden's instinct
to the extent it was a strategy i think
it was good now
almost 10 minutes in now a bit more
substantively
here is joe biden pointing out why would
you trust trump on coronavirus trump did
his routine about how great everything
was on coronavirus
biden points out trump's been wrong
about everything and he actually raises
the topic of injecting bleach and trump
has
no way to respond other to say it was a
joke which we know it was not
before november 1st it could also be
generally available
well we're going to deliver it right
away we have the military all set up
logistically they're all set up
we have our military that delivers
soldiers and they can do two hundred
thousand a day
they're going to be this is the same man
it's
this would be gone away by the warm
weather it'd be gone
miraculous like a miracle and by the way
maybe you could inject some bleach in
your arm and that would take care of it
this is the same said sarcastic that was
you know that i
any of you who remember that incident
know it was not sarcasm
trump has demonstrated no ability to be
capable of sarcasm
trump can do nothing that was a good
moment for joe biden
check out this comparison now between
how trump answered will you pledge to
accept the election results
will you pledge to ask your supporters
for calm in the aftermath of the
election
and will you accept the results when
they are certified this was the last
sort of main topic in the debate
and we're going to go to trump's answer
then biden's answer
trump when asked doesn't say yes attacks
mail in voting
and says this is ominously not going to
end well what's going on take a look at
west virginia mailman selling the
ballots
they're being sold they're being dumped
in rivers this is a horrible thing for
our country there is no this is not
there is no
this is not going to end well here is
trump again
wildly bringing in hillary clinton of
trying to
coo donald trump saying they have obama
and biden's crimes on
tape which is out of this world zany
and if you are watching you will notice
that joe biden seems visibly perplexed
by what donald trump is talking about
here
so when i listened to joe talking about
a transition
there's been no transition from when i
won i won that election
and if you look at crooked hillary
clinton if you look at all of the
different people
there was no transition because they
came after me trying to do a coup
they came after me spying on my campaign
they started from the day i won and
even before i won from the day i came
down the escalator with our first lady
they were a disaster they were disgraced
to our country
and we've caught them we've caught them
all we've got it all on tape we've
caught them all and by the way you gave
the idea for the logan act against
general flynn
you better take a look at that because
we caught you in a sense and
president obama was sitting in the
office he knew about it too so don't
tell me about a free transition
as far as the ballots are concerned it's
a disaster
a solicited ballot okay
solicit it is okay you're so listening
you're asking they send it back you send
it back
i did that if you have an unsolicited
they're sending millions of ballots
notice trump saying everything other
than i'll accept the results once they
are certified
talking about hillary when asked if he
will accept the results
this is an outrageous authoritarian this
is not about
populism or economic anxiety this is
authoritarianism
and then just a little more from trump
once again just horrible
trump telling his supporters go to the
polls and watch now
if you're not a poll worker you can't
just do this
you need to register as a poll worker if
you want to be at the polls
and trump again just trying to cause
chaos
so i first for you sir finally for the
for the vice president i hope neither of
you will interrupt the other
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
during this extended period not to
engage in any
civil unrest and will you pledge tonight
that you will not declare victory
until the election has been
independently certified
president trump thank you for joining my
supporters to go into the polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen
i am urging them to do it as you know
today there was a big problem in
philadelphia they went in to watch they
were
called poll watchers a very safe very
nice thing they were thrown out they
weren't allowed to watch
yeah trump complaining you can't just
show up and observe yeah well that's
called voter intimidation it's illegal
in most states i think hopefully all
whether it's enforced is another
question you can't just show up
now for contrast same question to joe
biden
and joe biden is able to give a one-word
answer and it's the only answer and the
answer is yes
i will accept the results when they are
certified and then trump still can't
contain himself
and interrupts and biden accurately
points out trump has no idea
will you urge your supporters to stay
calm
while the vote is counted and will you
pledge not to declare victory until the
election is independently certified
yes and here's the deal we count the
ballots as you pointed out
some of these ballots in some states
can't even be opened until
election day and if there's thousands of
ballots going to take time to do it and
by the way
our military they've been voting by
ballots
first sentence at the end of the civil
war in effect and that's
and that's what's happened going to
happen why was it not why is it for them
somehow not fraudulent it's the same
process
it's honest no one has established at
all
that there is fraud related to male
imbalance that somehow it's a fraudulent
process it's already been established
take a look at caroline maloney's racism
you had an opportunity
he has no idea what he's talking about
here's the deal the fact is i will
accept it and he will too you know why
because once the winner is declared
after all the
all the ballots are counted all the
votes are counted that'll be the end of
it
that'll be the end of it and if it's me
in fact fine if
it's not me i'll support the outcome and
i'll be a president not just for the
democrats i'll be a president for
democrats and republicans
and this guy i want to say honestly
gentlemen
would you say that's the end of it this
is the end of this debate this ballot
count
we're going to leave it there uh to be
continued
as in more debates so trump continuing
to talk
over everyone as the debate actually
ends trump's still talking
this is what a uh uh
this this is what an authoritarian
lunatic sounds like
now could biden have done better yes
biden could have done better there were
missed opportunities
for biden to point out incredible
hypocrisy from donald trump for example
when trump's taxes came up donald trump
said both
that the story about his taxes is fake
news and actually he paid millions in
taxes
and trump said i'm smart and i take
advantage of the tax law biden could
have said
he's talking out of both sides of his
mouth he's not being honest is the story
fake
or is it accurate but you're happy about
it because you're smart enough not to
pay taxes
which is it it can't be both missed
opportunity
another instance of this happening was
trump mentioning that his supporters
were allowed to be poll workers uh poll
watchers in philadelphia that was
towards the end of the debate
biden missed the opportunity to say you
can't just show up
you can't that's not how it works it's
voter intimidation
meant to suppress the vote but this was
the whole point
trump made the debate impossible now in
the end when we say
biden did okay but sort of stumbled and
trump was a raving lunatic
what's the impact i don't believe
trump's strategy of causing chaos in the
debate serves him well
trump was so erratic and furious and
unhinged
that the contrast with joe biden's
stability could not have been more clear
now you can say well but joe biden
sounded
confused in some moments after reviewing
clips of the debate now with you
and preparing for the show earlier today
my big picture takeaway is that while
donald trump succeeded at preventing
substantive discussion
because he's unable to discuss policy
substantively
he made the event a laughingstock biden
comes away
looking stable in comparison and it's
probably bad for trump
trump's outlandish behavior also by the
way allowed biden to take some shots at
trump
without them seeming uncalled for
because compared to what trump did it
was small potatoes
and that there are people who want that
there are people who want zingers and
biden had a few so
the big picture right now is the polls
have biden up six
on average there is no clear winner here
and donald trump really debased himself
so
i think it's bad for trump trump needs
to make
up six points biden did more than well
enough
not to lose a six point lead then the
question becomes
are people's votes counted but we have
to come to some
realizations based on last night number
one
if you still like trump as of last night
you're probably an authoritarian that's
something you have to think about you
know these claims of
well trump is a populist his message is
a message of populism
to appeal to economic anxiety there was
none of that last night
there was nothing populist about trump's
messages last night this was
authoritarianism plain and simple
and if you still follow him you're
either an authoritarian yourself
or you're indifferent to
authoritarianism either to own the libs
or for some other reason
but again my overall take is and i so i
know some people disagree with me
i don't think biden looked great i think
it was okay
but trump looked so chaotic that biden
looks good in comparison he held his own
he landed a few shots my guess
is that the debate was so
debased that the ratings for the second
and third ones will be lower
i had you know we were joking about
mercy bands during my stream i said if
you
if you want to be banned as mercy to not
be able to watch my streams of the
future debates let us know
i think that trump making it unwatchable
will turn some people away from the
future debates but
i don't think it helps helps trump big
picture um
what else is important to say uh
what else did biden do well i mean biden
was more substantive
biden laid out some proposals in terms
of clean energy
coronavirus economics biden did call out
a lot of trump's bs
including things that trump denied when
there's video of it happening i think
that that was good
biden correctly linked trump to the
violence that's happening
trump tries to link biden to violence
biden's not the president
i think biden did a good job of saying
this is true this is trump's america
right now
and then i do think that on the last
issue which
was that of voter fraud i think it was a
disaster for trump
trump blurted out fraud fraud fraud
joe biden very clearly said we're going
to accept the results when they are
certified
and there's no evidence of voter fraud
vote by mail is the norm
in a lot of places it's gone absolutely
fine
so you got the sense that in the second
half of the debate
biden was better equipped to deal with
trump's constant interruptions and was
able to get some of those good hits in
overall the debate wasn't you know it
was it was a mess it was an s
show as we would say and it was that 95
because of donald trump and 5 because of
chris wallace
we still have to see how it goes the
polls have tightened and we're going to
talk about that after the break but in
the meantime
let me know what you made of the debate
i'm on twitter at d pacman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to
refresh your style one of the best
investments you can make is in a high
quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top quality materials
and they just look great i went on their
site and picked out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store
when you go to davidpakman.com slash
vincero
i've put the link right underneath this
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay now i don't want to worry people
unnecessarily but we need to be
correctly concerned
correctly concerned that national polls
have tightened donald trump is closer
now to joe biden in national polling
than he has been since may which was
almost five months ago
these polls importantly do not yet take
into account the effect of the first
debate this is still all pre-debate
polling but we have to acknowledge
that it is looking less good for joe
biden today than it was looking
last month and the month before and the
month before that and if we don't vote
if we don't all vote we may all be
devastated on november 4th so looking at
the average of recent national polling
from real clear politics right now joe
biden's average lead
is 6.1 now on september 11th it was
eight
and on july 27th it was 9.3
and on june 23rd it was 10.2 so this is
not
the right trend now let's let's look at
it in a different way
in chart form so again june 23rd
bidens up 10.2 in the month that follows
by july 27th
biden's lead has dropped by just about a
point to 9.3
by september 11th biden's lead has
dropped to eight
another roughly point and a half and
then between september 11th
and today joe biden's lead dropped
1.9 points on average
this is not good this is not good when
you see a lead go from
10.2 to 6.1 in a few months
that's a 40 shrinkage
of the lead it's not small there are
also some recent polls that are not
exactly giving me too much comfort i've
highlighted some of them here
on this image which we're showing our tv
audience a recent national poll
has biden only up by two that's the
lowest we've seen in
a high rated national poll for a while
in wisconsin joe biden is only
up by two that's a state he had been
leading by more
on average biden is still winning but
seeing a poll in which biden's only up
two is not exactly encouraging
north carolina recent poll has trump
ahead after many polls had
biden ahead so this is not
panic oh no but it is this is not nearly
over
none of us should think it is and none
of the polls
sort of price in voter suppression
voter intimidation whatever donald trump
may be able to achieve through the
courts to stop the counting of absentee
ballots
none of that is even in the polls there
are also
some good indicators in the last couple
of days as an exam
example there's a poll out of north
carolina for the senate remember that in
north carolina you have incumbent
republican tom tillis
defending his seat against democratic
challenger cal cunningham
there's a new poll that has cal
cunningham the champ challenger up six
in north carolina that's great uh poll
out of georgia where democratic giant
challenger jon ossoff
is up by one against the incumbent
republican senator
uh perdue forget what his first name is
uh senator perdue
in georgia that's very very good but it
is not an exaggeration when i say
every race every state has to be fought
for
figure out how you will vote if you're
interested in voting absentee
go to vote.org slash absentee
hyphen ballot or just search google for
vote.org absentee ballot it'll take you
to a page
you put in your address it tells you how
you in your state request an absentee
ballot it's not too late
if you want to vote early you go to
google you type in vote.org early voting
the first result
is a page telling you how to vote early
in your city or town or locality
have a plan um we cannot
assume anything and when you look at the
you know
whenever i do this i get emails from
people saying david you are do
your gaslighting it's reverse
gaslighting i don't know what that means
gas lighting is gaslighting
you're gaslighting people into thinking
it's close
so that people will vote no i am
accurately telling you that joe biden's
lead in the
national polls has shrunk from 10 to
nine to eight to seven to six
over the last five months now you can
say six is still plenty enough to win
well maybe but what if six becomes five
and then you lose another two points
because of
suppression and biden wins the popular
vote by three but loses electorally then
what was should i have shut up come on
guys okay let's be responsible
we've all got to see the data we've all
got to have a plan here
hey this is really funny donald trump's
lawyer i guess i don't know if he's
still his lawyer rudy giuliani
appeared yesterday morning on fox news
propaganda show fox and friends this was
ahead
of the first presidential debate and
rudy giuliani
blurted out this rambling conspiracy
about joe biden having dementia and as
he did it
the looks on the faces of the fox and
friends hosts
are they look like they're sick to their
stomachs it's kind of like a bizarre
stream of consciousness take a look at
this first part from
rudy giuliani the man has dementia
there's no doubt about it i've talked to
doctors
i've had them look at 100 100 different
tapes of his
five years ago and today the biden
people say he's fine
he can't recite the pledge of allegiance
and he's fine he's been a
he's been he was in the center for 160
years
i mean so this is already weird because
rudy says
biden can't recite the pledge of
allegiance it's trump
who has visibly struggled to recite the
pledge of allegiance
and the national anthem and
biden's been in the senate 160 years
rudy is making no sense
whatsoever here and okay the fox and
friends crew is starting to look a
little bit concerned but rudy's not
slowing down he keeps it going
he can't do the prologues or the to the
constitution
to the constitutional united states or
the declaration of independence any of
them
he can't do numbers wow are the numbers
screwed up
he actually displays symptoms that two
gerontologists told me are classic
symptoms of
middle level dementia it's so weird
because this has turned into the
projection
campaign everything that rudy giuliani
is expressing
is a supposed is everything rudy is
saying as a supposed concern
about biden is actually something that
we're worried about with trump
actual mental health and neurology
professionals
have been sounding the alarm about
donald trump for years
and rudy giuliani is trying to apply all
of those criticisms
to joe biden let's continue that's when
he does that i pledge allegiance
to the united states um uh uh i think uh
done that twice that's a that's a that's
a classic symptom
and the dsm-5 is the fifth symptom of
dementia he's got he's got he's got
eight of the ten
look that isn't the debate he'll he he
can get through it
i think the president is quite right to
say maybe he's taking adderall or
a uh some kind of attention deficit
disorder
so you know then with the adderall once
again
it's donald trump who appears to very
clearly have
upper and downer days and it's donald
trump who the world speculates is taking
some kind of uppers could be adderall
could be abusing allergy pills according
to michael cohen
could be abusing nasal decongestants etc
it's it's
do they not see this do they not realize
every allegation
that donald trump uh rather that rudy
giuliani is making about joe biden
has been applied seriously to donald
trump now it gets so bad
that fox and friends hosts try to
interfere a little bit they try to help
out rudy giuliani
but rudy can't be stopped he just keeps
going uh a uh
some kind of attention deficit disorder
and that's why the president wants to do
a drug test but you know none of us are
yeah
this is just that's your opinion but so
it will be interesting to see what
happens tonight
it's not no it's not just my opinion
it's the opinion of a number of doctors
i've actually uh you know interviewed
right look let's talk about the supreme
court because that's going to be a topic
tonight at the debate
of course what are we and you hear brian
kilmeade there
saying we can stay away from this topic
and there is just
so much projection consider the
absurdity
of rudy giuliani rambling incoherently
through his claims that someone else has
cognitive issues
it's really incredible rudy mentions
10 dementia symptoms in the dsm-5
dsm-5 actually replaces the term
dementia
with major neurocognitive disorder
and mild neurocognitive disorder and it
doesn't list 10 symptoms i mean
everything rudy giuliani's saying here
is completely backwards
beyond the bigger picture that these
really are allegations that have been
credibly made about trump which have not
been answered
it's actually tragic in a way i was
never like a big rudy guy
but especially after 9 11 rudy giuliani
was
truly he wasn't universally loved
but in a polarized america after 9 11
rudy was
as close to universally loved as you
could imagine
and then be he became you know mayor 911
noun verb 911 became rudy giuliani's way
of speaking
he then jumped in with trump completely
and now he has sort of become it's
almost like he's the hatchet
kook who has to go around saying the
things trump would love to be saying but
finds himself stopping short of rudy
giuliani is the
guy out there doing it just an
irrelevant crackpot making no sense
whatsoever in a way it's sad what's
happened to rudy giuliani
and meanwhile at a recent rally donald
trump said rudy should really run for
mayor of new york again
i have a hard time imagining rudy could
win at this point
tell me if you disagree we'll have more
coverage
of all of the shenanigans surrounding
the first presidential
debate on the show's instagram page
uh you can find it at david pakman show
on instagram
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to
blinkist.com david pakman i've put the
link
right underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
it is great to welcome back to the
program richard wolff
professor emeritus of economics at my
alma mater the university of
massachusetts he taught me
introductory macroeconomics a long long
time ago
currently a visiting professor at new
school university in new york city the
new book
is the sickness is the system when
capitalism fails to save us from
pandemics or
itself and you you make the point in the
book that i've been making for some time
which is
that the pandemic exposed
the inherent fragility of many systems
which we take for granted this includes
the streams of income from our jobs
whatever they may be
this includes the food supply chain as
we very quickly saw in grocery stores
toilet paper the inability of government
our government others have moved far
more quickly but the inability of our
government to quickly react to changing
circumstances
give us the kind of big picture of what
what the takeaway should be
well i think it's a stark illustration
of something which
has been difficult for many americans to
get their
their heads around so let me be blunt
and make the point that the
the book makes uh in a variety of ways
if you think about it we all know that
we had a terrible virus back in 1918
killed six hundred thousand americans we
know very well how damaging viruses
are in recent years we have studied
mers sars ebola i mean
there is no excuse for a modern country
let alone a rich one let alone a an
economy with a well-developed
medical practice and education system
to be unprepared for a virus there
really
is no excuse and when you remember that
an economic system
if it has any priority the public health
of the people who live in it
has to be right up there number one two
or three
why in the world were we unprepared we
had companies that can produce
masks and gloves and ventilators and all
of that
but they didn't do it and i know why i'm
an economist what i study
it isn't profitable no company wants to
produce masks
uh by the millions store them in
warehouses around the country where the
population
is concentrated make sure that they are
clean
make sure that they don't deteriorate
replace those that do
watch the whole thing and then you never
know when the next virus will be
will you have to sit on all of this for
two years for six years
for 20 years so it's not profitable it's
not a rational
capitalist profit driven calculation to
make
so the companies didn't and we didn't
have the ventilators the gloves the
masks and all the rest
and there's no shorthand way of saying
it private
capitalism and the public health
don't work well together they don't
solve the problem okay we could have had
a secondary solution
the government could have come in and
said what i just said
private capitalism is not capable of
making us prepared for a virus
so we're going to do it we're going to
buy the masks as fast as you produce
them
ditto the ventilators ditto the gloves
and then we're going to store them at
taxpayer
expense in fact in warehouses and
distribute them
and monitor them and clean them and
replace them we'll do all that
because private capitalism fails the
government
is going to come in and compensate but
we didn't do that either
because our government is trapped in
this ideology
that somehow private capitalism does
everything
maximally efficiently maximally it's all
wrong
well they did have now they did have the
national stockpile right i mean in a
sense that's what it is it was
completely misdistributed
and they did nothing with it for months
but to some degree isn't that what the
national stockpile is
yes and and look we have plenty of
examples of where the government
can do it the best example that i use is
defense
right you know it's not profitable to
make a missile and store it for 10 years
or a gun or a ship or a plane but we do
it
is the government comes right in buys
the thing as fast
as the defense companies produce it and
then the government pays to store it
monitor it and clean it so we know how
to do it
but it wasn't done because we're so
ideologically blocked that what we can
do for defense
we won't actually do for our own
personal
public health we've been cutting back on
rural hospitals
we've been coming back on that stockpile
we
have now shown ourselves to have what i
mean here's the statistic
that i think ends all conversation the
united states has four and a half
percent
of the world's people and we have 25
of the world's covet cases and covet
deaths
we're a rich country that is a statistic
that screams something fundamental is
wrong if a society with our capability
has such a record so on the economic
response
which countries did best in terms of
dealing with the financial insecurity
the job loss as a result of social
distancing measures are what what are
the examples we should look to
yeah i'm afraid that there again i have
bad news but it's a bad news it's also a
wake-up call
yeah the united states did not do well
let me give you the starkest example
in the united states over the last six
months
the richest people in the country gained
tens of billions
more of their wealth those numbers are
well known i won't repeat them
over the same period of time more than
50 million people
had to file for unemployment
compensation
either by the state or the federal
government i mean a starker rendition of
inequality
you could not have at the same time we
were all telling each other
this virus is a great danger to all of
us we
all have to work hard together we will
get through this together
yeah some people got through it together
by becoming richer
and an awful lot of people are getting
through it
uh by becoming poorer because of
unemployment
why do i stress this in the european
countries it wasn't done
unemployment in italy during the entire
covid period
was less than it was a year before that
when there was no
uh coven german unemployment went from
five percent roughly in march to six
percent
roughly now in short in every major
european
country they did not do
what the united states did they didn't
throw tens of millions of people
out of work throwing them on
unemployment adding to their
losses of unemployment the unspeakable
anxiety of wondering whether they'd ever
have a job again
whether the job they lost would be there
when they went back
looking for it which we all know
millions of them won't we already know
that um and so they're all wondering is
the roulette wheel gonna come down and
point on me
uh to add anxiety
to the worries about the illness to the
worries about managing your children who
can't go to school
your distance i mean it's unspeakable
and let me tell you why
in europe the reaction was so much
better
the european leaders whether they're
right wing left wing or in the middle
they know the following labor unions
socialist parties communist parties
they're much stronger in europe
than they are in the united states and
that's been true for a long time
and everyone there knows if you had
dared
throw tens of millions of working people
out of their jobs
out of the security of their jobs they
wouldn't have gone home
to watch tv they would have gone into
the streets
and they would have shut down those
economies way
more totally than any pandemic
could and everyone there knew it
so here was the deal in europe the
government will help you
in your business but you cannot
fire anyone you get it
that's the condition and that was
accepted in europe
and that's how they've handled it here
in the united states
we don't have the political muscle on
the left
in the labor movement to create a
comparable
awareness so the trump administration
could
go ahead the democrats provided very
little
opposition even the afl-cio
hasn't had a demonstration to say this
is taking out the difficulties of a
virus
on the mass of people who have no guilt
whatsoever why are they singled out
why is it possible to impose
unemployment on 50 million people
while the richest people gain billions i
mean this is
beyond words and my book is an attempt
to try to get at how this came about and
how it
works so that people can contextualize
these awful results yeah the book is the
sickness is the system when capitalism
fails to save us from pandemics or
itself
we're going to go to a break on the tv
and radio show with professor richard
wolff but you'll be able to find our
entire conversation which will continue
on on the youtube channel
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world
famous bonus show every single day just
for members
as well as commercial free audio and
video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all
become a member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the new york times story leaking donald
trump's taxes on sunday night appears to
have blown
a much bigger story wide open which is
donald trump's very precarious financial
position and more importantly
how that precarious financial position
could make donald trump a very
susceptible target for all sorts of
blackmail and manipulation
remember that in the new york times
story along with telling us that trump
paid no federal taxes
for 10 of the last 15 years and paid
only 750
in federal taxes in 2016 and in 2017
and he wrote off seventy thousand
dollars in hair related expenses
it also told us that he's 420 million
dollars in debt
with 300 million of that in loans that
will start coming due during what would
be trump's second term as president if
he gets one
it's even worse than that dan alexander
looked at the full scope of trump's
debts including equity loans against
properties and other things
and estimates that donald trump's total
debt right now
is about 1.1 billion dollars now
this is a security nightmare this is not
just about conflicts of interest this is
not just about his trump a good
businessman or not
this is about trump being a national
security risk recall that back when
jimmy carter was president
jimmy carter put his stake in his
family's peanut farm
in a blind trust to avoid conflicts he
later sold it but initially he put it in
a blind trust
we are orders of magnitude beyond that
here trump's indebtedness is so
severe that if he were any other
government employee according to former
u.s attorney barb mcquaid
he would not even be able to get a
security clearance debt is one of the
most common
reasons that the government would reject
giving someone a security clearance
because
creditors can exert undue influence over
people
when they owe a lot of money if someone
knows you're strapped for money
that you have debt they can manipulate
you
and then on top of all this donald
trump's businesses have been
particularly hard hit because of
coronavirus
which we'll talk about in the next
segment but look at the irony
that trump's own mishandling of
coronavirus as president
has jeopardized his businesses as a
private citizen if he had better handled
coronavirus from day one
the economy wouldn't be doing as
terribly and trump's businesses would be
doing better
and trump's financial position wouldn't
be as precarious but for our
conversation
about national security the point is
that trump's 1.1 billion dollars in debt
are now being combined with increasingly
failing businesses which we'll discuss
shortly and it makes him
particularly vulnerable to coercion
to manipulation and this could actually
be a personal bankruptcy for trump
that's coming remember
when trump talks about being a
billionaire he doesn't necessarily have
billions in cash and in fact a ton of
his net worth as we now know
is held up in inflated property values
that's not cash you can
pay debts with and in fact it may be
wildly exaggerated even as
equity we have a president potentially
facing personal bankruptcy that's not
who you want in power
when someone is desperate for cash
they're susceptible to blackmail
they're susceptible to bribery and for
that reason people with massive debt
or in bankruptcy are not the people we
want with access to the nation's secrets
but there are no such rules for the
office of the president
and it's interesting that lots of trump
defenders are calling this stuff
conspiratorial look at the facts you
really don't need to speculate much
the president personally owes one or
more people
at least 400 million dollars and
probably 1.1 billion
okay as a fact his tax returns show it
other documents in the media have shown
that trump has tried to hide the reality
of his financial situation that's
undeniable he's gone he's in court right
now
trying to hide his taxes that's a fact
we only know
some of the creditors trump has that's
true we know some we don't know all
trump likely doesn't have the cash
to repay these debts because most of his
wealth is paper wealth
in real estate and intellectual property
that's a fact
trump is accused of laundering money
through his campaign
that's a fact now it's it's a fact that
the allegation has been credibly made it
has not
yet been proven we know that in general
people don't like being financially
insolvent that's like a general truth
about humans so
very little of this is speculative next
i want to dig in a little more
specifically to the business failings of
donald trump
so i've already outlined to you how
donald trump owes
not 300 million dollars not 420 million
dollars but likely trump's total debts
are about 1.1 billion dollars to various
creditors
and i've already outlined in the
previous segment how this makes trump a
national security risk
there's another piece to this and that
additional element
is that donald trump's businesses are
just failing right now donald trump's
entire resort business is collapsing
partially due to his own mishandling of
coronavirus and it actually goes even
further
trump's own desperation to open the
economy
could well be motivated by the desire to
rehabilitate
his own businesses what's increasingly
clear
is that were it not for donald trump's
reality show host career on the
apprentice
he might be totally insolvent because
his resorts
are true money pits trump actually used
a bunch of his apprentice money
to go and buy golf courses and resorts
around the world and they're all doing
terribly
of the 15 golf resorts that trump bought
as of 2015
almost none are profitable trump bought
doral
it looks like doral i guess he
pronounces it doral for 150 million
it's lost 162 million since his resorts
in scotland have lost
63 million that much band-aid about
hotel in washington dc
near the white house has lost more than
55 million dollars
between 2008 and 2009 the trump
organization
lost 1.4 billion dollars as his tax
documents show
and none of those numbers account for
2019 and 2020
and what's going on with coronavirus and
and by the way
trump alienating half the country
through his presidency
has not helped his business half the
country now
would not go to his resorts on principle
because he's a failed moronic president
he's damaged his
brand and his reputation through his
presidency
and then in comes coronavirus and it's a
disaster
partially because trump himself was slow
to deal with coronavirus
trump being slow to take coronavirus
seriously
has hurt trump's own businesses and this
gets us to why trump behaves the way he
behaves
why is trump dragging his entire
presidential entourage
with secret service to his own resorts
week after week after week
to funnel money into his failing resorts
why is trump desperate
to open hotels and the economy even when
it's too early during coronavirus
because he needs his resorts open
because they are failing
all of these stories connect golfing at
his own resorts all the time
demanding the economy open desperation
to win re-election no matter what
hiding his taxes through any means he
can
allegedly laundering money through the
campaign there is a grand narrative here
and it's that trump is failing
financially personally
may be at risk of personal bankruptcy
and he's desperate to stave it off now
one last thing
the big takeaway from all of these
financial revelations this week
should not be trump is a fake
billionaire there are too many people
focusing on that people on the left and
the right
the real takeaways here are systemic the
system
allowed a lunatic sycophant to become
president on the false notion
of being a successful businessman and
the electoral college
helped him despite losing the popular
vote that's a systemic issue
the system allows the super rich people
who are super rich at least on paper
like trump
to pay no taxes through various
mechanisms including
tax loss carry forwards and asset
depreciation
which i went over with you yesterday the
system
allows a president to funnel money into
their own businesses
with no repercussions trump has said
he'd be great for the middle class and
people should pay taxes
and he's been terrible for the middle
class and he doesn't pay taxes so the
story is not
fake billionaire the story is all of
these other things
which we should focus on 38 days from
now
after the election but between now and
then the election is the focus
hey here's a funny voicemail um in light
of donald trump deducting
70 grand for haircut stuff uh take a
listen to this voicemail i got
hey david this is dave from california
regarding trump's taxes i want to ask
you
a personal question would you be
deducting
the price of haircuts right when you do
the david pakman show
now you know you can so will you be
doing that
you know what's funny about this so so
first of all i don't spend 70 grand on
my haircuts
i spend 35 bucks i guess every two
months so that's like you know i spent
about 225
a year on haircuts my accountant said
it's one of those things that
i i can i can do it as a business
expense if i want because i'm getting
haircuts for a show
that if i were audited it could be an
area of disagreement
with an irs auditor but my accountant
says i would probably be fine
doing that uh but no i have not done
that yet and it's just not really enough
money
to make a difference but i i appreciate
you looking out for
getting every dollar i can in tax
deductions dave oh we've got a great
bonus show for you today get
instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches but
making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you fifteen
percent off when you go to
davidpakman.com
vincero today's show also sponsored by
blinkist blinkist is the app that lets
you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video